do you believe a filmmaker should edit
their own movie I mean yes sometimes
sometimes not it's you know I you know
I'm an editor and so I was just gonna
let that okay go back but here I'll you
and say you know I'm an editor and so
yeah I have that I like to edit and so I
like working with my own stuff but i
also know that's not always the best way
to go about something on this on these
micro budget level movies it is often
hard to have an in editor so i think
that was a you know we actually instinct
starting this movie we wanted to have an
editor on and then I was able you know
we had somebody who dropped out at the
last minute and then I was able to get
someone that I knew from film school to
kind of do a first cut for me on the
movie but you know he only had a certain
amount of time he could give you know it
wasn't a full you know get through like
a fine cut of the movie and so I took it
over from there and so yeah I definitely
wanted that for this movie but I also
really wanted to be doing some of the
editing myself just partly because I
enjoy just the physical you know working
with the material and that it's so
powerful that
you know there's a real rush of creating
something in the editing and you know I
mean making something i would probably
you know when i go make another movie
I'll probably look to have somebody else
at it partly for that experience and
because there is something in me that
thinks well you do lose a little you
know you certainly lose something if you
choose to edit it yourself you know and
but you know that's no reason that to
say that people can't I suppose
you